the couple at the very bottom and
leaving right now
is
brian and sharna kenya you're staying in
the show it's the end of the road for
brian austin greene and matt james on
dancing with the stars i was shocked but
that guy matt was in the bottom to begin
with yeah shocked and brian i mean and
everyone you don't know who's gonna be
in the bottom it was brutal
i think i would have been upset any
which way it went but like it was brutal
it was our two best friends yeah i was
very sad to see sharon and bryan go
wasn't expecting that and then
lindsay and matt was not expecting that
at all
pissed
i was so
so shocked like i i'm still in shock on
tuesday after all 13 remaining couples
delivered their performances on disney
villains night host tyra banks revealed
which three couples were in the bottom
two it came down to brian and sharna
burgess kenya moore and brandon
armstrong and matt and lindsey arnold
having earned the lowest combined score
from the judges and the lowest total
number of viewer votes brian and sharna
got the axe without getting a chance to
be saved by the judges the couple at the
very bottom and leaving right now
is
brian and sharna
and ultimately the judges voted between
the two remaining couples with head
judge len goodman making the final call
oh and i have to go for martin lindsay
i'm gonna save
kenya and brandon the couple i'm going
to save is matt and lindsey i'm gonna
pick
kenya you're staying in the show
about that moment
is when she dropped to her knees that
was a real vulnerable moment and like
when you see people come on our show
none of them have any idea how difficult
it is to be on dance from the stars they
see the glitter they see the glam they
think it's super fun and easy it's hard
work brian and sharna seemed to take the
elimination in stride and didn't seem to
be too surprised after receiving
mediocre scores for their waltz on
disney heroes night and their pasa doble
on disney villains night for villains
night which was better received by the
judges the pair hit the dance floor to
deliver a pirates of the caribbean
inspired number
[Music]
et spoke to judge carrie ananaba after
tuesday's show and she admitted she was
surprised by the real-life couple's exit
i think it's not easy to work with
someone that you're in a relationship
with so i give them so much credit for
being so professional and so elegant out
there every time and it's you know i you
know charter's like family right to all
of us so the beautiful thing is although
we're judging the dance we're all happy
for her and her personal life brian and
sharna's relationship has been a hot
topic all season with fans weighing in
all over social media some saying the
pair was at an advantage but when et
spoke with them last week they explained
why that simply isn't the case a lot of
people like to assume that we have an
advantage right oh it's an advantage
because they know each other you know
they're in a relationship they can
practice whenever they have chemistry it
is so the opposite people really do
think that this is all just fun and
games for us and we're just banking on
being cute and we want to you know do
kisses
mushy like love story and it's like man
the fact that like
through all of this like we are still
we still want to be affectionate
want to be around each other is it's a
major accomplishment for us
you